all right jamie mm-hmm
jamie uh where'd you grow up where were
you from originally um
originally i grew up in quito
it is a little town outside of
millington
in tennessee tennessee
and tell me about your childhood you had
both your parents when you were young
um half and half
had a really rough childhood really
really rough childhood um
but i excelled
i was top of my class smartest
for kindergarten
on up until i started dating a guy that
was way older than me
very abusive and i was scared to go to
school
so i went and got my ged
a little bit early when i was 16
and took some tests got to go do a
little bit of college
nursing school um
then i got vested for prescription fraud
but already had a full blown addiction
to pain pills
because of a car wreck
and it just kind of escalated from there
you know
pain pills your body builds up
tolerance constantly constantly
constantly
and i'm at the point now where
i'm doing massive amounts of fentanyl
and it's starting to not work
so i don't know what my next um
plan of action is other than having to
quit
after fentanyl there's not much left to
do isn't it
the pro-ethanol that michael jackson
died off of but
you're not going to find a doctor to
monitor that
yeah you know and you're also smoking
crack
i do i smoke crack to balance out the um
you know the nod and the sleepiness
i also do xenx have
severe high anxiety
[Music]
i've had several attempts in my life
i was stabbed in the back twice which
resulted in two open-heart surgeries
and i have a pacemaker um christmas time
last year
uh i uncovered a killer
that was killing girls around the
neighborhood
and he tried to kill me kicked me until
i had eight broken ribs
my liver was split in three places my
spleen was busted and my stomach was
blessed
i was dying they airlifted me to the med
cut me from here to here and um
left me open packed my insides for six
days
closed me up the minute i woke up from
surgery
they couldn't give me enough pain
medicine in the hospital
so i am aid myself
what is that ama against medical advice
up and left directly after surgery
that's insane so let's go back to your
childhood
what was your childhood like was there
any abuse or anything like that
there was alcoholism in my family there
was abuse
mentally and physical a parent was
removed from the home
and when that happened a divorce
happened and the other parent
went a little bit buckwild so
i had two brothers and a sister that
were younger
i cared for them as much as possible my
mom would come and give us money
you know pay the bills but pretty much
it was a
free-for-all party house at my house we
had a
acre big race track for dirt bikes
in my backyard and also a racetrack for
bmx bikes
our house was the spot to hang out
you know for all the teenagers in tipton
county
so i i started selling drugs
you know whatever i can get my hands on
i did really well
until like i said i was
i was busted for prescription fraud
and i had actually got pretty far in my
nursing degree
um screwed that all up
um i also have uh
had charges of counterfeit money making
counterfeit money facilitating a
counterfeit enterprise
187 000 worth
of 100 bills counterfeit
um my husband signed
indictments affidavits on me i divorced
him
they had no major proof so um
they had to drop it way way down to
paraphernalia of you know
counterfeit materials so
i did a little bit more detail time and
um
but so that's my uh it's a little bit of
my background
i learned early on there was
[Music]
sexual abuse not from my mom or my dad
but from a man my mom
chose to be with and um
there were there was massive abuse there
how old were you from
what i can gather and from what people
tell me
i was probably four when the grooming
started
and i remember i was um
i was 14 i
not quite 40 it was like two weeks
before my first 14th birthday
when um the actual
penetration happened and uh
so it it screws up your
your sexual mentality it
it really does it it twists your mind
into thinking that um
that's all men want and then that's how
you get them
you know and it it made me feel like i
wasn't worth
you know anything and
i was uh one of the top softball players
at my school like i said i was
one i had one of the highest gpas
if i would have not gotten my ged
and finished until 12th grade i probably
would have gotten
a historian of my class
i was student council president from 6th
grade to 10th grade
regardless of anything that you know
went on in my home life
i still excelled in that in those things
um
i love working i'm an extremist whatever
i do
i do i'm the best at what i do
no matter if it's selling drugs selling
[ __ ]
selling whatever i um
i try to to be the best at it and
um and i am most the time but
uh so does this life get you down
sometimes you get depressed oh yeah
that's right it must right oh yeah
yeah i mean it must be difficult for a
woman to do this kind of work
without being high or drunk or something
oh yeah
almost impossible yeah
because mindy grades you
not all of them but a lot of them
i'm i'm a
a fetish fantasy girl i do a lot of
fetish fantasy work
and a lot of men have um
some pretty serious fetishes you know
[Music]
um some of them want you to
uh to act like their daughter
you know have daddy-daughter sex
some of them want um want
to rape you you know they'll come in and
act like they're gonna
they're raping you and then at the end
they'll pay you but
you know it's but
in in a week's time i'm i'm probably
raped
four times a week
um you become detached
what's the hardest part of this do what
what is the hardest part of
this life for you
the fear of
not seeing my kids again
of dying and not seeing my kids again
did that one trick who
tried to kill you is that what kind of
put this fear in you or
i mean the fear is always there isn't it
do you know what um
do you know what a necrophiliac is
somebody who likes having sex with dead
people
yeah for a long time i had a
necrophiliac
hot on my trail wanting to
um you know
um he wanted to
to have sex with me i dealt with that um
extremely terrifying
[Music]
from from what i gather he's no longer
in the picture
um it's a hard knock life out here
this must be far from the life that you
dreamed about as a kid right
far from it i wanted to be
a lawyer or a veterinarian
and now with your addictions it seems
very unlikely you'll get out right i
could still be a lawyer
i have enough school under my belt that
i could steal
no anything is possible you know
fentanyl is a tough drug to crack it is
prediction i'd actually um overcome it
uh and relapsed
so what do you think the
the core of all your self-destructive
behaviors is family
no family support yeah
the people that do make it have family
support
i have a huge family um
but no support it's like oh my gosh
you know they smoke weed and drink
take little pills you know but oh my
gosh
hearing foot and fitting all we can't be
a part of that
so you're disowned you know and
and i know you don't
get clean for your family
but when you have
the people that you love surrounding you
encouraging you
it makes a big difference and and also
having a home to go back to i can't go
back to my
childhood home i'm not allowed
so i have to do what i have to do
to to put a roof over my head
do you find the requests you get from
your
customers gets a little extreme
sometimes
it's beyond what you're comfortable
doing sometimes
sometimes they ask for bestiality
do you know what that is they want they
want you to
have sex with one of their animals
absolutely not some want to
um to
get four or five people and
and beat you and rape you but they offer
a thousand a piece
but you know that's that's out of the
question
um there there's a lot of
um some want you to [ __ ] in their mouth
you know that's
not something that i'm into um
people have um fetishes that
i don't really see how they um
they come about them
you know i know how i came about my
fetishes i have fetishes
um i like to be
dominated i like to be tied up
you know i'm one of those
i like toys i like minor amount of pain
um you know my sexual
um preferences or
uh i don't know what you would call it
my sexual
orientation or whatever it isn't exactly
exactly healthy as a doctor would put it
or whatever but it works for me you know
so um i also
don't know whether i like men or women
more
my last relationship was a with a woman
a girl named christy and
she died three months ago
i'm sorry that was hard
you know um the hardest part about all
this
is is watching everyone
you know around you die
because that's what happens
jails institut institutions are death
that's that's the end of this road
and um even
having the knowledge of that we still do
it
the fentanyl the heroin
i've been addicted to every drug and was
able to overcome it
the fentanyl and the heroin
it it's a whole whole other level
it changes the chemical makeup of your
body
um it's absolute
the your your biggest fear
then becomes being sick
off of you know not having those drugs
that's your biggest fear
you would rather die yeah then um
you know go through that uh sickness
so um
you know but and and then
people get through it but your body
never really
recovers so you think well
i'm just going to try it again and
one time and you're hooked again it's uh
neverending cycle
who's raising your children um well my
son
is old enough to you know
he moved up to missouri with his father
finally
and they're doing really good building a
relationship
my daughter has always lived with her
with her dad
my children have different dads and
when me and my little girl's father
split up
she uh he took her and i took him
and um off and on he's had to go live
with his granny
and my mom when i've had to go to jail
and stuff
but um when he uh
when he really left me
for a little while because he wanted to
go to dallas with his granny
and try something new it um my addiction
really soared
that's when it got really bad
he came back i slowed down
a lot but um he was older he
was bigger than me and um had a lot of
anger
and a lot of um he wanted to fight me a
lot
and i couldn't find him
so uh he's with his dad in missouri now
[Music]
uh from what i hear they're doing good
he's almost 18
he's working so um
that makes me really happy wherever my
kids are
as long as they're safe and happy and
protected
that's what that's what matters to me
you know i'll sacrifice my feelings and
my hurt
so that they're safe and well taken care
of
and what's your biggest regret
my biggest regret was um
going to see dr
and um getting on
pain medicine
because before that i i really didn't do
drugs i didn't even smoke a cigarette
and um when i got on those pain pills
prescription i thought prescription and
they're okay
he wrote me he was a script writer he
wrote me
a panda i don't know if you know what
that is it's
oxymorphone they give it to dying people
percocet lortab xanax valium
fentanyl i got all that a month in one
month
and um that's my biggest regret
i feel like if i never went to him then
i
i never would have you know
gotten a pill addiction and that's what
started it
because once you're addicted to pills
your body becomes dependent
and so what's been the
most important lesson you've learned
this way of life drugs
all of this um
nobody's above it it can happen to
anybody
the best of us the smartest of us
um it happens very quickly
and and that's
i guess that's it that you know
nobody's immune to it nobody
you get an addiction your morals change
and um until rape is a
normal part of your of your life
all right jamie thank you so much for
sharing your story
you're welcome i wish you the best of
luck with thank you
getting out of this street life thank
you an addiction
thank you